hey guys i'm viviane and today we're
going to have two teams compete to guest
angels and their scene secrets but can
you figure it out before they do
[Music]
hi angel how are you doing i'm good
vivian how are you
i'm ready to find out your secret and
expose it to the whole internet are you
ready for that
i'm an open book let's see if they have
what it takes to figure it out okay so
our first team is team a can you
introduce yourselves hey
what's up i'm mae i'm matt
and we're teammates we are the power
team the power team
okay power it up team b can you
introduce yourself next hi
mom i'm famous oh i mean uh youtube
we're team b aka the best team i'm shawn
and i'm chelsea and while we're shouting
at our moms
what's up mom okay so here's how the
game works
both teams have three rounds of 90
seconds to make their guests based off
yes or no questions that they're going
to ask
angel and guys we really want you to
participate so come up with your guesses
and put them in the comments below
first team that guesses correctly wins
the game and if no one guesses then
angel wins
angel we're ready for your first hit i'm
ready my first
hint is that this is something
horrific that happened to me in college
okay something horrific that happened to
angel in college
team a you're up first team b we're
gonna mute your sound
okay 90 seconds around the clock team a
go
okay i feel like there are so many
places to go does it have to do with
other people or is it just you
yes or no oh other people just have to
other people
yes did you get hurt yes
oh oh did you break anything
no okay
was it outside
got a minute outside yes uh
was this early on in college yes
yes which one
[Music]
you regret it or do you regret this
i guess he said horrific so i don't
think it was something that he would
enjoy
um does this have anything to do with
one direction
no was it in front of people
yes 30 seconds on the clock does it
was there a tree involved
[Music]
almost were you intoxicated
no was there a car involved no
15 seconds on the clock do your friends
know about this
yes do your parents know about this
no on you no
five seconds almost a tree involved what
the
all right we yield our time for the
moment you have no time to yield because
the time is up team a we are going to
mute you
and bring back team b okay team b
you guys were having a lot of fun back
there but now it's your time to shine
so 90 seconds on the clock go
was this during halloween yeah
did this evolve a professor teacher or
professor's assistant
no does this oh does this involve
uh anything with food no
[Music]
does this involve skipping class
no but i did that a lot i know i know
you i always keep guessing
things like that okay keep going sean go
does this involve you being class
president
now one minute on the clock does this
involve
a lot of food yeah this is this is
involved
what does this involve like
with another person yes
this is about someone with the same
gender
i can't sorry does this involve someone
with the same gender
yes did you say something to their face
that you regret
no did you do something to them that you
regret
no 25 seconds reveal personal
information about themselves
to you no you guys have a dance off
no did you guys do did you guys do
something together
i guess 10 seconds on the clock
is he your ex no do you want him to be
your ass
no not when you find out this secret and
your time
is up team a and t b
you have 30 seconds to chat on the side
and figure out what your guess is going
to be
okay so angel while they're chatting
let's chat
because i feel like the fact that you're
revealing a horrific secret to the
internet is very brave
what made you feel like this is
something that you are ready to talk
about
um i
it's horrific but i'm not like scarred
by it i guess
you know i'm an open book i like to
share things
um okay so we're back team a what's your
guess
okay so our guess is it's your freshman
year
you're at like some type of rally and
you climbed a tree
and then you fell out of it and you
didn't break anything
but almost just your dignity you broke
when you hit the ground
dignity is a painful thing okay so team
b what's your guess
you had a meeting with this guy that you
set up to reveal a big secret
and once you both got to the meeting you
were like
never mind and you were like too
embarrassed and you never confessed your
love
and that was it okay horrific
okay so two very different guesses for
this
horrific horrific horrific
embarrassing secret angel are any of
these right
uh unfortunately both are very incorrect
so sad so sad okay well that means we
have to move on to round two
[Music]
okay angel i think everyone is ready for
your second hit
amazing viv uh my second hint
is my my my do i love australia
hey guys you heard it my my my he loves
australia
so team b you're up first team a we're
gonna mute your sound
and we are putting 90 seconds on the
clock starting
now was the guy that you met australian
no is this secretly of finding nemo
reference 442 p sherman walt dbway
sydney
no i never realized i was in australia
huh uh
is was there australian food
no does this involve a kangaroo
[Music]
no does it involve any type of
australian wildlife
one minute on the clock you covered
another person in
vegemite and played a prank and said it
was [ __ ]
no ah i don't know
chelsea go i'm freaking out um did you
win a spelling bee
with the capital of australia as the
final word
does does this person have a sexy accent
[Music]
someone involved does uh does this
involve a teacher
less than 30 seconds your love with the
serenade in another
pretending to be one of the like uh
uh famous australian celebrity
no does this involve like injuring
yourself
injuring no does it involve a confession
no less than 10 seconds does it involve
a fall
or a prank no
[Music]
what and with that what
your time is up where fast your time
is up okay so
team b we're going to put you on mute
team a you're up
time starts now
your your hint it was in reference to
troye sivan yes
yes okay well i have no idea what the
hell i'm talking about then i thought it
was a reference to down under like you
fell on your bum
okay did you meet him i have many times
but this is not that
and not a scenario okay wait wait angel
yes or no questions
so now were you performing
no i was not does it have to do with
down under like your rear end
no
um um was somebody else performing
no it was outside and it has to
the toy spawn okay um was troy there
no was he playing was no
37 seconds on the clock no no did
somebody look like troye sivan
no does it have to do with a boy
yes were you on were you on a stage
did the man look like troye sivan
absolutely
did he know troye sivan maybe
okay that's not the answer hurt yourself
and it has to do with troye sivan
were you like running after something
and you fell less than 10 seconds
no were you in a car no were you on a
bike
three seconds were you looking for troy
womp womp time is up team a team b
it's time for you guys to chat and
figure out what your guesses are gonna
be
okay so angel mae just laid down
an awesome amazing hint do you think
this is going to change the game
i definitely do uh team a is definitely
impressing me
with their questions and
i think that uh they're on the right
track
um but this final round is really gonna
be the make or break for this situation
okay so we are back round two time for
the guesses
team b what's your guess so i we think
that angel being a huge fan
of troye sivan thought he saw a student
that was troye sivan
ran over to him at his school tackled
him down
and jokes aside he found out it wasn't
him and he was embarrassed
tackling interesting okay
team a what's your guess so we also
are on the choice of on train with that
great hint so we are gonna say that
angel um because he got hurt you know he
got into a
fight over with a good friend over troye
sivan
and um it ended up with angel getting
a henna tattoo of troye sivan
oh angel team a and t b
just threw you some more guesses are any
of them right
uh unfortunately no none of them are
right uh
but we are we're headed in the right
direction
okay no one had a correct guess for this
round so we are going to move on to
round three
the final round okay so angel we're
ready for
your last final hint yes
okay so my final hint to you all is
i don't know this is just the type of
love that'll just
skewer you right in the heart team a
europe first and team b
we're going to mute your sound okay 90
seconds on the clock team a
go angel did you bleed from this
yes oh
does it involve a breakup no
does it involve a needle no
okay did somebody else make you bleed
yes
did somebody stab you yes
what the [ __ ] um was it like
accidentally stabbed you hold on was it
accidental
no one minute on the clock did somebody
get mad at you for saying that you were
a bigger trolling fan than them and then
stab you
no did somebody stab you
because of something that had to do with
choice of on yes i love how it works
move further
[Music]
not directly but yes
so congratulations to team a and um my
condolences
angel what happened on my way to go
get troye sivan tickets happened to be
the day
someone stabbed me and ran away on
campus um um i didn't even go to the
health center i
still went to the like office i was
going to to go get the tickets that i
got
are you okay i'm totally good i still
have the scar
can we see it no it's like in a like
almost private area
congratulations to team a for figuring
out this stabbing answer
congratulations to angel for surviving
and
guys let us know in the comments below
if you figured out the answer before the
rest of them did
we'll see you next time